[Applaudissements]
j'ai trouvé que c'était pas idiot de me
proposer à moi de d'évoquer l'idée de se
relever en politique parce que j'ai eu
de temps en temps la tête dans les
étoiles mais plus souvent les pieds dans
le gaz de schiste donc c'était une
occasion de partager cette expérience
avec vous ce qui m'intéressait c'était
de parler de ce moment particulier où on
prend la foudre sur la tête
soit on est balayé soit on revient très
fort et pour ce qui me concerne le jour
où j'ai pris la foudre sur la tête
c'était à 27 mai 2014 à propos d'une
affaire qui a défrayé la chronique qui
l'afer bygmalion je rappelle les faits
brièvement c'est une affaire qui est
arrivé pendant la campagne
présidentielle de nicolas sarkozy en
2012 où les dépenses pharaoniques de
l'époque avaient conduit des
organisateurs de cette campagne a pensé
qu' on allait dépasser et qu'ils
allaient dépasser le plafond autorisé
et ils ont eu cette idée folle de faire
en sorte que ce soit l'ump qui paye les
excédents et naturellement sans jamais
que je n'en sois informé ni que jamais
on en parle
vous allez dire c'est bizarre on est
président de l'ump on doit savoir tout
ça l'avait été c'est quand on est
président d'un parti politique
en fait on signe jamais un chèque on
vous regarde pas les factures c'est
statutaire de telle manière qu'on évite
les dérives du passé et ainsi je n'ai
donc jamais été informé tout cela
jusqu'au jour où la presse sur la base
de dénonciations
comme souvent dans ces cas-là a rendu
publique cette manière illégale de
procéder et là je suis apparu comme le
bouc émissaire absolument idéal sur la
base d'un alignement d'un alignement
d'intérêt complet d'un certain nombre de
gens hommes politiques jalousie n'est
jamais loin
les places sont chères et quand on veut
être président de la république comment
dire il ya un seul lit pour plusieurs
rêvent les journalistes ou un certain
nombre d'entre eux toujours heureux de
pouvoir se dire on va faire un peu de
commerce avec ça et puis
la vindicte populaire la haine ce 27 mai
2014 ya eu un bureau politique que j'ai
présidé et je me souviens très bien de
trois images très fortes ce jour là la
première le déchaînement de ceux qui
sont dit c'est le moment ou jamais pour
le faire tomber
wauquiez barrot 1 nkm
fillon non il fallait vraiment que je
parte la deuxième image d'un journaliste
qui avait qui dirige un journal epoch
s'appelait le point et qui avait mené
une campagne de presse déchaînée
copé est coupable j'ai fait condamner
après première instance en appel pour
diffamation mais ce jour-là il
comme andy rihs resplendissait il va la
télé et il dit c'est très bien
copé va retourner dans les égouts c'est
sa place les égouts scélérat dans
l'imaginaire les années 30
et puis la troisième image est un peu
différente c'est celle de mon fils aîné
kim envoie un sms depuis warwick où il
étudie en angleterre papa je t'aime tu
es le meilleur
c'est rare un que vos enfants vous
envoie ce type de sms vous verrez plus
tard je l'appelais tout de suite il y
avait une petite voix au téléphone qui
voulait juste savoir si j'étais encore
vivant je dis oui c'est dur mais
rappelle toi ton grand-père 1943
aubusson la rafle sauvés par des justes
ça c'est les vraies épreuves bon et puis
ces jours là il faut tenir tenir tenir
tenir jusqu'au soir journal de tf1 pour
dire aux français qu'on est innocent
jusqu'au jour où dix-huit mois après la
justice m'a totalement innocenté
totalement dans l'indifférence générale
il n'y a pas une ligne dans la presse
entre temps j'avais tout perdu l'enquète
était terminé 14 personnes mis en examen
renvoyées devant le tribunal
et moi totalement innocenté mais j'avais
tout perdu
je voudrais partager avec vous trois
réflexions
la première c'est de vous dire qu'enfin
tous autant que vous êtes il faut se
préparer à l'idée que peut-être un jour
on peut avoir une grosse épreuve
professionnelle c'est consubstantiel à
l'ambition consubstantielle à la
réussite est donc à la jalousie
congénères il faut donc mentalement se
dire que ça peut arriver et qu'il faut
pas être dans le déni
deuxième leçon que je tire de tout ça
c'est que en fait on peut jamais
l'empêcher parce que tout est organisé
pour que quand la foudre vous tombe
dessus
en fait vous voulez vous le voyez pas
venir et je vais même plus loin
les équipes qui vous conseille ce sont
comment vous dire des sacs de confiance
des hommes et des femmes qui se battent
pour vous mais un cercle de confiance
c'est toujours un cep de vulnérabilité
et dans le management c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut jamais oublier
puis la troisième leçon je voudrais
partager avec vous c'est que la vraie
grandeur c'est de savoir faire face et
savoir faire face dans ce type d'épreuve
d'abord c'est dans le moment le moment
où ça explose c'est tenir le gouvernail
parce que la tempête est très forte et
tant que la tempête s'est pas arrêtée il
faut tenir bon avec les quelques années
qui restent
ensuite il faut commencer à reprendre un
peu de recul renouer avec la dialectique
du temps court et du tad du temps long
et hiérarchiser les priorités rester
solide dans sa tête
travailler sur soi même ne pas craindre
de se parler à soi-même pour essayer en
se dédoublant de tenir le choc et puis
le troisième élément de la grandeur
c'est le moment où une fois que l'orage
est passé de revoir un à un tous ceux
qui vous ont poignardés c'est des
moments assez baroque
il m'est arrivé d'entendre l'un d'entre
eux me dire oh la la qu'est ce que tu as
pris un des durs j'y mets tu te souviens
pas d'un an était souvenais plus les
phénomènes de meute ont ceci de
particulier que ceux qui poignarde n'ont
qu'une idée en tête l'occulté
psychiquement pour les années à venir
et puis et puis il faut
à preuve d'humour chacun son antidote
rien de tel que l'autodérision surtout
quand on a la réputation d'être un peu
sinistre pour terminer un petit message
un petit clin d'oeil quand vraiment y'a
rien qui va il faut les se choisir un
héros un gars qui a illuminé votre
enfance et qui vous donne envie de
rebondir
il y en a qui me quitte jamais moi j'ai
pas prévu de slide c'est juste une image
10 euros il combat l'injustice et quand
il tombe de cheval il s'est toujours
remontés et repartir au combat
je vous disais au début de mon propos
quand vous prenez leur âge sur la tête
soit vous disparaissez soit vous êtes
alors dotée d'une force que rien ne peut
arrêter c'est l'image 2 euros merci
[Applaudissements]